égaré dans une mine j'ai remarqué les 3
x sur votre nuque sas tiens puisque vous
visez la tripe condamnation trafic de
voitures coups et blessures et votre
petite cascade maison mais si vous
faites ce que je vous demande je ferai
en sorte qu'on passe l'épongé sur tous
vos crimes
voyez pouvoir jouer à ce petit jeu avec
moi oui lui lbeq vous avez la
possibilité de rembourser la nation pour
toutes les libertés dont vous jouissez
on est où ici pendant des placards à
gadgets high tech de la haine et st
sam bot
on s'y connaît en vrac est super est un
je veux que vous rencontriez les
personnes et que vous pourriez votre nez
dans leurs affaires
quel genre de personne louche dangereuse
des personnes de votre genre cas peut
voir les filles les orgies mais c'est
que tu ne vois pas c'est ce qui se passe
la journée ils tueraient des millions de
gens c'est un agent secret je vais tout
ce qui lie à dehors dedans
peu après couverture a foiré rentrez
chez vous vous foutez de ma gueule quoi
je croyais qu'on avait un deal j'ai
changé le deal
qu'est ce qu'il faut pas faire pour son
pays
allez dire
mal du tout
rindy seul
nom de code triple x